Jerry, squeeze my hand if you can hear me.
All I know is how to be a writer...
There is nothing more sacred than "story."
How does that sound, Mr. Salinger?
Through the course of my fascinatingly dull life, I've always found fiction more truthful than reality.
I write short stories
Have you been published?
You're not the first wise-ass that I've taught.
I can't stand all these flits and phonies.
So what do I do now?
You're a writer, what do you think you do now?
Write another story?
And then another one after that.
How is writing a real profession?
And then another one after that!
I don't know if I'm cut out for this.
Maybe not
Are you willing to devote your life to telling stories?
There's no harm in dumbing it down once in a while
You're trying to be clever on every page. It just doesn't feel real
What makes you think you have anything to say to people?
You can enrapture people,
Move people
I just want my writing to be truthful
To the best student I've ever had. Stay alive
War Hero doesn't always get a parade. Sometimes he blows his head off
You've gotta stick out these dry spells
I think Holden Caulfield is a novel.
No I couldn't write a whole novel
Holden Caulfield deserves an entire book
People think it has a lot of problems.
I just don't buy Holden.
He's old and supposed to be crazy
They don't want to publish it
I went to war with these guys over this
War? You went to war with these guys? I saw them all get killed. I should be dead too, I shouldn't be here
The pages of this book were with me when I stormed the Beaches of Normandy
I don't think I'd be alive if it wasn't for this book
You're Holden Caulfield right?
Imagine the book that you would want to read and then go write it